en fait l'histoire c'est il y a 4 ans en
fait je vais acheter ma maison ouais
donc vers chez à côté de chez toi et du
coup donc je demande je demande à mes
conseillers forcément ben après pour
pour ce bien là et il me dit que c'est
pas possible c'est mieux de louer
par rapport à
l'argent que tu as placé je mets quand
même j'ai quand même voir ce qui se
passe et j'ai un ami qui est courtier
j'ai tu peux pas me trouver un crédit je
vais acheter une petite maison à Mougins
tu regardes pour moi mieux que je
regarde et il me demandait pas pied
quand il me demandait papiers si tu veux
il me dit ouais mais là ça va pas lu
d'autre tu as des nantissements tu peux
pas sortir de l'argent donc du coup je
mets le nez dedans je commence à parler
avec mes conseillers aujourd'hui voilà
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'ai de l'argent
qui est sur le sur mon compte les
assurances vie
je peux pas sortir non parce que on a
menti tous les biens que tu as achetés
c'est à dire les maisons de retraite on
a lentille tout en argent et en fait
ça t'appartient pas à quoi ça
m'appartient mais il faut que je Vendee
bien et je lui dis mais comment je peux
avoir autant d'argent et pas moi après
ma carrière je suis une maison donc
voilà donc j'ai commencé à appeler des
avocats parce que tout seul on y arrive
pas et à partir de là j'ai commencé la
procédure et je me suis rendu compte de
beaucoup de choses et qui tu t'es rendu
compte de quoi en fait il y avait il y
avait des commissions qui étaient
pratiquement triplés alors que au départ
c'est des conseillers donc il te
conseille sur sur des choses qui
prennent leur commission sur sur le bien
je veux bien mais après dans dans
l'immobilier prendre aussi une
commission sur sur le notaire les choses
comme ça donc du coup petit à petit tu
te rends compte tu mets le nez dedans tu
dis voilà les maisons est-ce qu'elles
valent ce prix là tu fais expertiser
contre expertiser et tu vois que tu te
fais tu te fais avoir sur toute la nuit
sur des millions donc voilà après je
suis pas moi la chance que j'ai c'est
que j'en avais encore un peu pour vivre
et pour être bien sûr mais c'est aussi
par rapport à tous mes potes et tous
ceux qui sont dans le monde du Sud du
foot de mannequins l'acteur je veux dire
voilà on se fait tout savoir
sur le soleil Captain Marlow vous êtes
gentil vous ouais
pour tous les jours
tous les gens qui gagnent énormément
d'argent excuse-moi mais surtout que moi
j'ai aidé pendant j'étais joueur j'ai
des dégâts qui étaient à la rue quoi
en parler et du coup moi j'ai des héron
j'ai des j'ai donné par rapport à mes
connexions ben des places pour qu'ils
travaillent je me suis dit c'est un truc
de fou quand même mais ça n'arrive ça
m'arrive à moi mais Ludo encore toi que
tu as dit voilà tu avais encore tu avais
le côté externe mais moi je suis
rencontré
un immense footballeur un mec vraiment
équipe de France des clubs étrangers
Hainaut et je vous jure il n'avait plus
un euro il était obligé de vivre chez un
pote je te vraiment c'est un truc de fou
n'en parle pas et en fait ils ont tous
honte de ça on dirait que c'est de leur
faute mais il faut comme on dit à chaque
fois Raymond comme il dit c'est
récompensé gagner beaucoup d'argent tu
peux mettre de côté tout ça mais en plus
quand tu t'es fait arnaquer et qu'en
plus après tu as la honte aussi tu sais
de le dire comme a dit Ludo tu dis dans
la rue tout le monde me reconnaît et en
fait j'ai même pas je peux même pas
trouver un logement je peux même pas ce
qui est ce qui est dingue c'est que là
en l'occurrence vous racontez que
c'était pas parce que vous avez flambé
et fait n'importe quoi vous aviez des
conseillers qui au contraire était censé
préserver ce patrimoine vous étiez pas
inconséquent parce que parfois on dit
oui mais il avait qu'à gérer là en
l'occurrence tu l'as pris des gens pour
gérer visiblement et ce sont ces gens-là
qui vous ont mis sur la page le problème
c'est qu'à 17 ans tu tu te retrouves
professionnelles donc tu as ton agent
qui te qui te conseille il te dit voilà
ben nous moi je travaille avec cette
boîte là donc tu fais confiance c'est
ton agent et te fais gagner un peu
d'argent ton premier contrat pro et
après tu dis bon ben voilà moi ce qui
m'importait c'est quand même payer les
impôts
les parents ils m'ont dit il faut
toujours péter des impôts c'est
important donc j'avais juste cette
phobie par rapport aux impôts mais après
le reste je payais des gens
qui sont censés m'aider et justement
gérer mon patrimoine aujourd'hui il y a
de plus en plus d'argent dans le foot
les joueurs sont très entourés très
conseillés est-ce que vous pensez que ça
pourrait arriver aujourd'hui ce qui vous
arrivez c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y a des
joueurs gagnent encore plus que nous et
qui se font encore arnaquer aujourd'hui
mais c'est sûr
et certain après je parle pas que il y a
pas que les agents ou les ou les
conseillers il y a les copains il y a
les cousins la famille il y a beaucoup
de choses il y a beaucoup de gens autour
de nous et c'est vrai qu'à un moment
donné ben il faut faire attention juste
temps en temps mettre le nez dedans
réfléchir à ce que ce que tu veux faire
après te vendre du rêve donc un moment
donné tu crois aussi tu dis bon bah sur
notre carrière entre 15 et 20 ans donc
tu te dis bon bah moi je vais mettre au
maximum de côté et puis je vais faire ma
retraite tranquille on a des enfants on
a aussi marié on va divorcer peut-être
ça nous coûte de tout ça ça nous coûte
de l'argent et on pense que oui on a je
suis pas là pour me plaindre j'ai gagné
ma vie je suis heureux d'être là et d'en
discuter mais ça va vite l'argent part
très vite et on a 40 ans à vivre et
c'est 40 ans il faut vivre
tranquillement il y a un rythme de vie
en fait tu vois c'est ça qui est en
train de vie qui est qui voilà et que ça
va très vite mais bon c'est vrai que
Ludo lui c'est surtout des des mauvais
des mauvais conseillers quoi après c'est
vachement important ce que vous dites en
fait vous êtes un lanceur d'air parce
que vous en parlez même si ça va pour
vous malgré tout en fait c'est des
jeunes qui mangent foot qui vit foutent
qui dorment foot ils sont dans des
sortes de formation hyper jeunes et en
fait ils ont personne pour aller
vraiment les conseiller ils ont
forcément aussi des mauvaises influences
et les clubs les aident même pas en fait
jamais driver
presque ça quoi mais en fait pourquoi je
moi j'en parle aujourd'hui parce que si
tu veux
avec qui avec qui je travaille avec
sport par exemple avec la boîte que je
travaillais a été rachetée d'accord
patrimonial et en fait si tu veux moi je
me suis mis à table on est de racheter
la boîte venez on s'assoit et on discute
de savoir comment ça s'est passé
pourquoi ça s'est passé comme ça ça fait
4 mois il me répondent pas j'y attends
je suis quand même là je demanderai à
personne vous voulez jouer au con bah on
va jouer au courant moi je connais moi
je connais du monde je serai sur toi ou
à la radio
je me lance et on verra mais en tout cas
par rapport à tout ce que je vois et
tout ce que j'ai entendu comme histoire
j'étais obligé de le dire ce que je peux
pas garder ça pour moi par exemple c'est
pas facile pour vous c'est vrai
d'exposer ça sur la place publique
est-ce que des gens autour de vous ont
dit tu ne devrais pas on va te juger mal
est-ce que vous avez hésité avant de
parler moi j'ai pas hésité parce que moi
je parle toujours avec mon cœur avec ce
que je sais moi j'ai pas volé mon argent
j'ai travaillé pour ça je sais d'où je
viens je suis pas là pour dire ouais on
me doit je suis à la rue non j'ai des
amis à moi qui sont à la rue et ça ça me
donne encore plus parce que je peux pas
les aider donc aujourd'hui j'ai pu je
suis plus footballeur j'ai une vie j'ai
des enfants donc voilà donc à un moment
donné je dis stop aussi à ça donc du
coup c'est aussi légal de dire voilà
il y a personne qui en a parlé il y a
personne qui en parle je suis le premier
et j'ai pas de problème de prendre tout
ce qu'il faut dans la gueule c'est pas
un problème moi j'affronte je dois rien
à personne je voulais personne j'ai tué
personne donc je viens ici pour en
discuter pour moi mais surtout pour les
autres tous les amis